is the s22 ultra really that much better  than the s21 and the note 20 ultra let's  compare the displays samsung made a huge  deal about their 1750 knit display which  is incredible let's go ahead and take a  look at hdr video to see how these  compare and there it is the s22 ultra at  the top looks dimmer than the rest well  i'm glad they went back to this design  i'm glad that unlike the note 20 you  could have the full resolution and you  can have the high refresh rate and the  battery got a little bit larger and we  have better graphics performance but at  the same time you're spending a lot of  money and in the real world we're not  seeing that much of an improvement in  performance so if you already have a  note 20 ultra i would not upgrade  very similarly same thing with the s21  ultra it's hard to justify upgrading  maybe if you want that a little s pen  built in that might be worth  [Music]  you